Andrés Manuel López Obrador salió a la
defensa de su reforma electoral que
levantó la polémica en México luego las
multitudinarias manifestaciones del
domingo el mandatario respondió
catalogandolas como racistas y clasistas
y calificando la escena como un
striptease político Entonces lo de el
INE fue una
excusa una bandera los que se
manifestaron ayer
lo hicieron en contra
de la transformación que se está
llevando en el país
la propuesta de López Obrador contiene
múltiples aristas que generan
controversia y despiertan acusaciones de
querer acaparar el poder la más
importante es la sustitución del
Instituto Nacional electoral y la
creación del instituto nacional de
elecciones y consultas un ente que
centralizaría toda la Organización de
las elecciones y le quitaría el control
al gobierno opositores acusan al
mandatario de querer acumular poder como
el caso del presidente de la cámara de
diputados Santiago grill
las mexicanas y los mexicanos salimos a
las calles a defender nuestra democracia
levantamos la voz y dejamos muy claro
que no apoyaremos la de forma electoral
que propone el presidente México no es
de un solo hombre es de todas y todos
la reforma también apunta una reducción
de 200 diputados 32 senadores y que los
consejeros y jueces electorales se han
votados por el pueblo entre una lista de
candidatos confeccionada por el
presidente la Corte Suprema y El poder
legislativo por ahora el partido López
Obrador no tiene la mayoría
parlamentaria necesaria para que la
reforma avance pero se esperan intentos
para conseguir apoyo de legisladores de
otros partidos